who from the original cast were you able
to connect with lucy's a dear friend of
mine that support and blessing means the
absolute world do you know who a is
i was really susan leo out here i was
real stressed about miss mouse yeah
there are definitely similarities
between my character and mona switching
our show does easter eggs really well
there was a fun theory that karen and
kelly are actually triplets and there's
a katie in the basement mallory are you
playing a third character named katie
[Music]
are we gonna see any familiar faces come
out of the woodwork to make an
appearance on original sin you're the
only journalist by the way that we've
talked to today who asked one of the
four trigger questions i see you both
smiling
every town has one
the scary house across the street from
the cemetery
where the girl lived alone with her
mother
and something terrible happened
in millwood
that girl
was me
the entire cast of original sin you've
made it so clear that you guys were
massive fans of the original pretty
little liars series so i'm curious who
from the original cast were you able to
connect with as you were preparing for
this role on original sin lucy's a dear
friend of mine and was really kind of
with me through the whole process of
finding out if i got to be a part of the
show or not and and just held my hand
through every step of the way and then i
remember being so nervous about the
announcement and all the beautiful
ladies sent their love to me i know
they're all really excited for us and
and excited to see what we get to do
with the show and i think on behalf of
all of us um that support and and
blessing means absolute world what was
the biggest takeaway that you got having
lucy there kind of as your guide through
this process you know i think she just
wanted me to enjoy it i think she was
just like enjoy every second and trust
yourself which is something that you
know as a young woman it can be really
hard to do in this business you have so
many outside noises and expectations and
yeah she's just a friend at the core and
we all need a really good friend by your
side so it yeah meant meant so so much i
know sarah shepard is really really
excited the author of the books really
excited for us and so to feel that love
just all around for all of us has been
huge because we we were big fans of the
og and it can be
a bit nerve-wracking to kind of step
into that world and and we definitely
feel the weight of the responsibility to
do it justice we're meeting lucy
tomorrow
so nerve-racking because lucy was like
the love of my life during my early
teens i actually was obsessed with her
and i like i really did have a weird
obsession with her i loved her
so i'm very nervous about it what are
you gonna ask her what are you gonna say
to her no i'm just gonna be happy if i
don't faint
composure maya composure
i'll be holding you from behind
i'm actually going to get so emotional
malia i'm going to need you i'm going to
be like
oh my gosh you can just fall into me any
time and i'll lie here and make sure
your eyeliner still looks perfect fine
i know
malia how about you have you connected
with any of the original little liars
they've been so um warm on social media
which has been just such a blessing
because all we want to do is make them
proud yeah
just being like so iconic in our life
there was a wonderful day on set
where my first look had come out i
posted it and was so excited and sasha
peters commented and tagged me this
beautiful message mean girls are so fun
to play like just enjoy every moment i
became so hot my heart dropped i was so
so excited forgot how to speak like
needed bailey to
help me i'm like well what do i say it's
sasha yeah it's been so amazing to see
how supportive they all are and you know
they don't have to say these things and
they aren't it's so nice it's really
sweet
i love how original sin is giving its
own unique twist on the character of a
so just point blank
bailey do you know who a is do you think
i know i think you know do you know i
don't know
chandler do you know who a is what i
think i know
i think you both definitely know
let me ask you this
will we find out by the end of season
one a's identity do you think you know
that
[Laughter]
you were there you filmed it
let me ask you this two can keep a
secret if one of them is dead which
means that be real bad for you right now
don't off me don't off me so i just
can't answer that for you
okay
okay
malia do you know who a is
well we were definitely left guessing
for a while um our characters had no
idea and neither did we as actors we may
or may not know who a is but that may or
may not change between takes would you
guys like throw ideas out at one another
or theorize about who a could be oh hell
yes we have so many theories i mean we
sat with this information for nine
months so imagine the amount of
conspiracy theories that we had going on
we also were like searching the stage
for for old drafts to see if we could
find any clues we would go to the stage
to see if they were building a new set
if they were building a new set with
somebody's character name on it would be
like okay this is it when you say
conspiracy theories can i hear your
wildest one we've thought about it all
we thought about it being we were like
is it one of us
is it
anybody in our family is it anybody
already like anywhere and i'm terrified
of talking about this because i'm the
spoiler one in the group i spoil
everything i was really susan leo out
here i was real stressed about miss
mouse why because she's so into
technology she seems pretty savvy
she's very smart yeah there are
definitely similarities between my
character and mona's which is really
nice i think our show does easter eggs
really well and and to have like some
likeness has been really cool as a fan
again but um i can promise you i'm not a
zarya do you know who a is
and i have to tell you point blank i
don't know if i can say we didn't know a
lot about our stories because we would
get the scripts like a week or two weeks
before filming and so it was this
amazing experience that we were on that
we were just kind of felt how the
audience will feel we were coming up
with our own theories and all of that
stuff can you share with me
maybe the wildest theory that you threw
out about who a could possibly be there
was a fun theory that karen and kelly
are actually triplets and this was eric
this is my dad the man who plays my
dad's theory eric johnson i think is who
started it but there's a katie in the
basement and uh katie's really upset
that she's not able to come into the
real world that that's the craziest one
i think i can think of malory are you
playing a third character named katie i
don't know
am i i don't know what aren't they
telling us
[Music]
you know we're always hyper analytical
looking at the clues looking at the
props in the background lindsey what is
the one thing you would advise to
original sin viewers that they
absolutely must pay attention to oh
interesting
i think i'd be remiss to say uh to not
pay attention to our horror eggs and our
original pll easter eggs if you're a fan
of the original pll i think you will and
hope you will love the easter eggs that
really kind of start in earnest about
halfway through it and pushed on to the
end i shot the first
easter egg when like it was a little
name somewhere and it was really
exciting for me to shoot because i knew
the name but they never told me this
miserable just read it i was like this
somebody knows somebody's name that i
know so i would say pay attention to the
little things pay attention to names on
i don't know if i could say it pay
attention to little things pay attention
to the little things in the background
or like little specialty shots and that
will give you guys clues there is so
much detail woven through our show every
frame every setup was thoughtfully
crafted yeah just pay
pay close attention and don't be so
close-minded like
allow yourself into the world and i
would say don't count
anything or anyone out okay if there's a
red flag lean into it analyze it it
might mean something yeah or it could
set you in the complete opposite
direction so
can you tease if there's gonna be cameos
are we gonna see any familiar faces come
out of the woodwork to make an
appearance on original sin we're not
allowed to answer that question
there's like a list of four questions
we're not allowed to answer and that's
one of them you're the only journalist
by the way that we've talked to today
who asked one of the four trigger
questions i am oh my goodness okay then
i'm doing my job you are you are i see
you both smiling i'm going to take that
as a
positive step in the right direction
we are so
dead whatever happens we're all in this
together
all for one and one for all
by the end of season one will fans have
closure will they have some sort of an
idea of a's identity i think that
roberto and lindsay do a great job at
closing circles they are such pros at
story arcs and knowing where something
is supposed to end i think absolutely
people will feel satisfied can you give
me some sort of a percentage or a
likelihood of how many of these
characters we're meeting that are gonna
make it out alive by the end of the
season
it's a great question i will say that
when we were breaking out the season
believe it or not we really wanted to do
a slow burn grounded version
so one way of doing that was keeping the
body count
low at first i will say that the deeper
you go into the season the higher the
body count
gets by episode four or five many people
you've already met will won't
be there
at the end let me just say that that's
all i'll say
[Music]
you